there's eric hosper is back in after his
greatest performance
as a padre
3o pitch coming up
osmer is taking that's ball four three
walks in the inning load the bases
padres trying to cash in and here's
myers
and he chops it down the third base line
and tagging the bag is escobar three men
left after one no score two down four
tatis who grounded out to lead off the
ball game for the padres
that is ball four
he wasn't sure
he's going down to first base he's so
locked in he forgot the count two one
and two ounce for grisham who was a base
on ball candidate his first time up
here's a pitch
swinging a ground ball to first nice
stabbing stopped by lamb gives the
gallon covering for the out at first
two on the end
one out and here is nick ahmed
line towards right field over his myers
and he almost overran it has to lunge
backward to make the catch
well that became an acrobatic type play
in right field for myers and he almost
overran it
what the cirque de soleil is going out
there in right field tommy pham walked
his first time up today here's the drive
to right field calhoun going back and he
leaps to make the catch at the wall
robbing tommy pham
oh that one looked like it was gonna go
calhoun's got a
gauge his leap as he's got the warning
track and times it perfectly osmore
watches first
played appearance
in the year to right center field that
is hit well martay going back at the
wall that ball is gone eric cosmer hits
a home run his first of the year and
puts the padres on top one to nothing
nice start to the year for haas two out
thunder for the pod race the throne is
the dh today
took one on the elbow had the elbow
guard on there looked like he didn't do
anything to get out of the way he's
calling him back he said he leaned into
it
well ripper's got torrey in his book
once already
one ejection already i should say now
make it two and tory lavello has been
ejected from the ball game
kevin krohns at bat will continue crone
goes down swinging on that slider cutter
six strikeouts for richards big spot
here for fam
fam with a fly ball headed towards right
field back goes cole calhoun he's there
to make the catch shy of the track to
end the end first two half reached and
here is starling martay who has struck
out three times today over three
chops that one fair down the line
starling martay with a base hit the ties
the ball game it's 1-1 at petco park
[Applause]
up the middle
right to tatisse
but that'll give the diamondbacks the
2-1 lead as pearlth is home from third
cronenworth at third base meyers at
first and
here is garcia
garcia sends it to center field that
ball is going to fall for a base head
connorworth will come homeward and score
as the padres have tied it up to the two
[Applause]
greg garcia with a pinch hit rbi single
to center and it's tied up at two top of
the order fernando tatis jr coming up
two for two
against archie bradley
that is strike three tatis takes it and
he throws the bat and not happy at all
but the padres have picked up a run and
tied this game two to two
and that is ball four back-to-back walks
allowed by kirby yates that'll load him
up
jammed him inside that time
grisham is in center vargas coming home
throw was cut off rbi for catalan it's a
3-2 diamondbacks lead
[Applause]
pitch swinging bounces it through it's
into right center lecastro will score
easily
make it 4-2 d-backs second base hit
today for peralta who hustles into
second
2-2
and fam drives one to left field peralta
going back still going it's going to be
caught out there in left field
what a catch by peralta and back to the
bag at first goes grisham
wow that looked like it was going to get
over his head for sure and peralta
reaches up and makes the catch running
back under the dirt of the track
fam looking out there like what just
happened
to right field and that ball is going to
get in
conan sent it to the wall coming around
from second base is chris and he will
score and it's a one-run
game padres are not dead yet
first major league hit for conan work
and it's an extra base hit
congratulations to the kid
jammed them with a fastball back to the
mound archie recovers and the
diamondbacks have their first win in
2020.
a comeback win in san diego 4-3 they
beat the padres
feels like a 900-pound gorilla just
jumped off their backs